hello there this is the Kauffman trying
out a new macbook webcam today I'm going
to talk about little things that have
influenced my life let's start with this
little item here dental floss I was told
by my dental hygienists that my gums
were receding i started flossing and my
gums have come back marvelous little
thing dental floss very very important
here's another one this is a little iPod
shuffle I have it with me all the time
in my pocket tuck to my shirt I listen
to my languages Russian Portuguese you
name it I can listen over and over again
I can listen to difficult content by the
easy content this used to be when I
started learning languages when I was
studying Chinese 40 years ago this was a
great big open real player you know tape
recorder so major major improvement now
in contrast to these little powerful
things we have other things that are
bigger and not so effective books for
learning languages here's one I bought
forty fifty dollars making progress in
Russian 550 pages there's 25 pages of
content all the rest is all kinds of
explanations about what happens
sometimes except when it doesn't happen
and all kinds of rules of Russian that
if I really took them seriously would
have quick learning Russian 5% content
95% waste of time and that's actually
very difficult of textbooks and before I
got involved with link because I started
learning Russian before we had link i
bought lots of books lots of books books
books and they're all the same and then
oh and then you've got 501 Russian verbs
I don't even look at it I should have a
great garage sale here get rid of all my
books all you really need is what we
provide now free Utley you've got
content you've got text you can learn
the words and phrases it's light so I
keep things on my computer I download
them to my little iPod shuffle and away
I
a little things that help so there you
have it keep it simple travel light
enjoy what you do and you'll succeed